SCP-682 Vs SCP-743.
Could the world’s most terrifying chocolate
fountain, filled with an endless supply of
omnivorous insects, finally be the thing to
fell the Hard to Destroy Reptile?
Initially, there seemed to be hope.
Exactly as the Foundation intended, 682 consumed
some of the delicious chocolate, marking it
for death by the nightmarish creatures lurking
within.
The swarm soon burst from the fountain and
began attacking and devouring SCP-682.
The creatures consumed 21% of 682’s mass
before the monster finally fought back.
It evolved a long, anteater-like tongue that
it used to catch and eat many of the insects.
The insects and 682 fed off each other for
days.
And after the two were separated, having consumed
743’s chocolate appeared to have temporarily
given 682 heightened regenerative abilities.
After observing this, the researchers concluded
that the two anomalies should never be brought
into contact again.